it's never too early to get excited for
the next big blockbuster right from a
bevy of superheroes to re-imaginings of
your favorite classics clear your
calendar all the way through 2019
because here are just a few of the big
budget flicks you're going to want to
get in line for now
Hellboy stranger things star David
Harbor will unveil his new take on
Hellboy in January 2019 joining director
Neil Marshall for what's described as a
gritty take on the original Mike
Minneola comics Harbor has said the
movie will use a darker tone to
differentiate itself from Guillermo del
Toro's adaptations adding that it'll be
more of a character piece about Hellboy
struggle while harbors take on Hellboy
looks spot on the rest of the cast is
also packed with potential including
Milla Jovovich as the villainous blood
queen ian mcshane as hell boys adopted
father and Sasha Lane as Alice Monahan
the movie has also signed lost Daniel
Dae Kim to play comics favorite major
Ben thymio the real question however is
if there will be pancakes glass M night
Shyamalan continues his surprise
superhero trilogy with glass a sequel to
2017 split whose final act unexpectedly
tied in with to thousands unbreakable
the movie will bring back all the main
players from both films including Bruce
Willis samuel l.jackson James McAvoy and
Anya Taylor joy details are still under
wraps and given how much Shyamalan loves
twists it'll probably stay that way
until the film's January 2019 release
date silver and black Sony spider-man
universe gets a female lead entry in
February 2019 with silver and black
headed by The Secret Life of Bees
director Gina Prince bifid who also
directed Marvel's cloak-and-dagger pilot
for freeform she'll also assist with the
script alongside thor ragnarok script
the movie is set to follow marvel's
mercenary silver sable
and the burglar black cat in a pairing
that prints both wood compares to Felmy
and louie's the dark film will
reportedly bring in the cyborg
supervillain gaunt and his enforcers
tarantula and scorpion as the villains
yep this guy
be spider-man taken out by the one nice
coffee chaos walking your next favorite
why a adaptation will hit theaters in
March 2019 with chaos walking a sci-fi
adventure based on the trilogy by
Patrick Ness the movie takes place on a
planet where almost all the women have
been killed off by a virus and living
creatures can hear each other's thoughts
as the story begins a young man played
by Tom Holland meets a woman played by
Daisy Ridley and she may have the key to
unlocking the world's many secrets
though it's not as if Daisy Ridley is a
girl with mysterious powers as much of a
stretch the movie has an amazing
supporting cast that includes Oscar
nominee Demi and Beshear two-time Golden
Globe nominee David Oyelowo
Tony winner Cynthia areevo critical
favorite Moz Mickelson and pop star Nick
Jonas mark your calendars now Dumbo
Disney has given a number of Animated
Classics the live-action treatment but
one of the most intriguing is Tim
Burton's Dumbo starring Colin Farrell as
Holt a former circus performer whose
life is turned upside down after he
returns home from the war all teams up
with circus owner max Medici played by
Danny DeVito to care for a newborn
elephant whose giant ears have already
made him a laughingstock the movies
all-star cast also includes Michael
Keaton Alan Arkin and Ava Greene with
Burton and a whole host of amazing
actors on board this should be a worthy
retelling of the classic tale when it's
released in March 2019 probably without
these guys the voyage of dr. Doolittle
putting down his Iron Man helmet for a
while Robert Downey jr. will put his
stamp on the legendary character of
Doctor Dolittle in April of 2019 the
voyage of dr. Dolittle like its
predecessors will also be based on Hugh
loftiness original children's books the
movie comes from a script by Syriana
Stephen Gaghan who's also set to direct
plot details are unknown but we can only
hope down he gets the chance to use his
glorious pipes should the movie end up
being a musical like the 1967 original
Aladdin Guy Ritchie will reveal his
ambitious and non-traditional take on
Aladdin in May of 2019 with Meena Masood
taking on the title role alongside Power
Rangers star Naomi Scott as Jasmine who
landed their roles after beating out
thousands of hopefuls in a worldwide
casting call the
rest of the cast includes Will Smith
stepping into Robin Williams role as the
Jeannie and Marwan kins re playing the
villainous Jafar the cast also includes
Saturday Night Live's Nasim pedrad and
into the woods Billy Magnussen we have
trust in the Disney machine to make this
a magical trip to the theatre cowboy
ninja Viking Chris Pratt made a very
quick journey from Parks and Recreation
schlub to action hero and his big 2019
outing will find the actor taking the
lead in cowboy ninja Viking based on the
image comic series of the same name this
time Pratt is a new kind of assassin
who's able to combine the skills of
three legendary kinds of heroes it's
been a long time in the making Pratt
first signed on in 2014 but when he was
unable to film due to his hectic
schedule a couple directors dropped out
waylaying things further still with
script work from Deadpool's Rhett Reese
and Paul Wernick and The Hangover 2's
Craig Mazin this ridiculous premise has
a pretty good shot at paying off winner
ninjas not entertaining top gun to
maverick will be back in july 2019
oblivion director joseph kosinski is set
to reunite with Tom Cruise for the
long-awaited Top Gun sequel which will
be set in the world of drone technology
and fifth-generation fighters and the
end of the era of dogfighting producer
Jerry Bruckheimer is on board to return
for the sequel and while it's unclear
whether other actors from the original
cast will be back Val Kilmer has said
he's ready to step up should he get the
call Artemis Fowl millions of readers
remember Owen call furs Artemis Fowl
novels or their graphic novel
adaptations which followed precocious
criminal mastermind Artemis through a
series of fantastic adventures around
the globe the books are ripe for the
film franchise treatment with Kenneth
Branagh set to direct an adaptation
scheduled to arrive in theaters in
August 2009 teen while no casting
announcements have been made yet this
looks like a family-friendly film saga
in the making Jim and I man Will Smith
fans have more than just a Latin to look
forward to in October of 2019 the actor
is also set to star in angley's Gemini
man as an aging assassin trying to get
out of the business things get
complicated when he has to fight against
his own much younger clone Jim and I was
first pitched to Disney over 20 years
ago but the execs had to wait until
visual effects could effectively change
the age of the lead actor this promises
to be a futuristic action thrill
with a nifty twist and twice as many
Smith's is never a bad thing or is it
sharks have been around for longer than
trees that was hard to believe but it's
actually true James Bond 25 Daniel Craig
returns just one more time as James Bond
in the characters 25th feature film in
November 20 1949 s denis villeneuve
heller high waters david mckenzie and 71
jian de menthe are reportedly the
frontrunner to direct a lot about the
movie is still being hammered out right
now but none of it threatens to revoke
double-oh-seven s long-standing license
to kill at the box office
Wonder Woman - as the D ceus
highest-grossing film to date in the US
it makes sense that Warner Brothers
quickly ordered a sequel to Wonder Woman
set to be released in December of 2019
the movie will also bring back director
patty Jenkins as co-writer while plot
details had been kept tightly under
wraps Jenkins has said she'd liked the
film to bring Dianna to America after
the events of Wonder Woman and before
dawn of Justice the sequel is also
reportedly said to have found a way to
bring back Chris Pine so look forward to
more action fun and maybe even a super
villain without a silly mustache thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]